in a fight between two co-workers ended
with one person dead
it happened near business close to lamb
and craig now metro police telling us
apparently these two
co-workers agreed to fight on their
lunch break and several other employees
followed them down the street so they
could watch
well prior to that fight starting one of
the men involved in that invited his
friend to come
and then during the fight that friend
began shooting
we know that employee number two was
losing the fist fight and that's what
prompted his friend to pull out a gun
and start shooting so in the midst of
this incident a couple of employees who
were not involved in the fight were both
shot
and one of them died the others in
critical condition
the employee who was said to be winning
the fight has a non-life-threatening
injury and police are now looking for
the employee who was said to be
losing and the friend who started
shooting so if you know anything about
this situation you're urged to call
crime stoppers the number there on your
screen is 702-385-5555